This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Harry’s.[a]
Cleanliness is close to Godliness, or so those
Midwestern Mom's used to tell me, but does
that mean dirtiness is close to devilishness?
Yep.
It does.
Thanks, science!
My mother HATES it when people aren't clean
in movies.
Seriously, during Lord of the Rings, she liked
it at the beginning, but as they went on was
all like, "Why can't they just take a bath?
They're all so dirty!"
It's a running joke at home, but science seems
to indicate she might have tapped into a little
piece of human nature.
A new study published in Organizational Behavior
and Human Decision Processes found the simple
act of being clean promotes ethical behavior,
while being disgusted will make us lie and
cheat.
The emotion disgust is a complicated one,
its roots are in revulsion, unpleasantness,
and can be tied to some phobias and anxiety
disorders.
When people feel disgust, according to the
findings of this study, they'll try and protect
themselves and their logical brain doesn't
interfere -- it's a self-protection instinct.
According to their findings, this instinct
lets normally ethical people lie to protect
themselves; or, in the case of their experiments,
for financial gain.
They figured the best way to avoid revulsion,
would be to introduce them to cleaning products
and cleanliness -- and it worked.
In people who were asked to evaluate cleaning
products, or just to think about cleanliness,
the disgust was diminished and they didn't
lie as much.
This isn't the first study into emotions affecting
decision-making.
A 2009 study in Psychological Science found
people whose office smells cleaner will be
more ethical too!
Because the office workers feel more comfortable
and all they did in that study was spritz
the room with window cleaner.
It even increased interest in charitable donation
with 22-percent of those in the "clean" room
expressing interest as opposed to six percent
in normal room.
We'd love to see our decisions as independent
from outside influence, but that doesn't seem
to be the case at ALL.
And it's not just smelling clean or thinking
about cleanliness.
A study done at the University of Amsterdam
in 2009 found people who held heavy clipboards
took things more seriously than those holding
light ones.
They literally gave more WEIGHT to things.
Not even a metaphor!
// I mean, it is a metaphor… but…
Sitting in a dimly lit place, or wearing even
sunglasses, can ALSO affect our decision-making.
Another study by the same researchers found
people in a dimly lit room would lie about
how many tasks they've completed in order
to get a larger monetary reward.
Being shrouded makes people feel anonymous,
and that anonymity makes people less ethical
and more self-interested as well!
This all makes me think of dirty, dim bars
and how much debauchery goes on there.
Maybe for reasons related to these studies?!
Opposed to that... those super-clean rooms
of the future make me feel a bit uneasy, like…
i'm too unethical for that!
Maybe mom had it right all along, in another,
related study, the same researchers determined
that people who had just done something unethical
felt physically dirty and cleansing themselves
made them feel better… so maybe I should
go shower.
Thanks, Mom.
Speaking of grooming, it is currently the
month of Movember.
And if you’re keeping that nice big fat
moustache all neat and trim, Harry’s can
meet your shaving needs.
A big shout out to Harry's.com for sponsoring
this episode.
Harry's was started by two guys who thought
buying razors was crappy.
They bought up a blade factory in Germany,
because German efficiency, and are selling
you their high-quality German blades on their
website!
They also have real nice face moisturizer
and shave gel, the ladies think it smells
nice.
Go to Harrys.com and get $5 off your first
purchase by entering the code DNews!
Thanks again Harry's.
Have you ever noticed these mental biases?
Are you going to find the darkest.
dirtiest bar you can think of this weekend?